on va parler aujourd'hui d'audio de
casque on va parler de casques à
réduction de bruit
est ce que vous connaissez la société
diva corps alors je vous présente jo
wilfried tsonga qui a eu un partenariat
avec la société dit vacants alors diva
corse est une entreprise française qui
est labellisé french tech et qui créent
des casques depuis de nombreuses années
des casques à réduction de bruit plein
de projets enfin des produits super cool
l'ag autour de mon cou un casque qui
s'appelle le diva corse et le hey joe
qui est un casque à réduction de bruit
active plutôt cool je le relève parce
que sinon je n'entend absolument rien
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de vous
présenter non pas ce produit qui est
déjà sorti il ya quelques temps mais qui
est quand même toujours aussi cool c'est
de vous parler dans tous vos pronos très
de deux nouveaux produits de la marque
dit d'accord ce sont des petits bugs des
petits écouteurs intra auriculaires sans
fil j'ai rencontré le big boss de
pigboss de la marque dit d'accord
lorsque j'étais à l'ifa berlin
j'attendais un petit peu avant de vous
en parler aujourd'hui c'est le jour
aujourd'hui je vous en parle je vous
ramène avec moi à berlin pour découvrir
de nouveaux produits et vous allez voir
vous n'allez pas être déçus
[Musique]
on est avec david de diva corps big boss
des ailes à quoi les divas corps fans de
métal besoins pendant le hellfest alors
diva corse est une entreprise française
est-ce que vous avez passé encore aux
cadres start up ou plus tous certes un
peu voilà on a démarré déjà depuis sept
ans maintenant mais c'est donc on a déjà
évolué on a déjà des productions
commercialisées dès on est plus sous
l'appellation start on est une start-up
évolué en et en développement en
développement en phase de développement
on a déjà passé l'étape start up mais
développement quand exposé au moma new
york c'est que déjà table c'est vrai que
là c'était un peu la panacée en mars on
a eu l'honneur d'être des élus dans la
catégorie troue et laisse donc les 100 %
sans fil avec le modèle antipodes
sélectionnés par le moma le musée d'art
moderne à new york sa claque alors
vraiment un peu dit d'accord avant de
parler des produits parce que vous avez
produit effectivement casque sans fil
connectés qui l'a développé ça n'est
présentement un peu la boîte qu'on
comprenne plus que vous faites qui vous
êtes tout ça tout ça quoi d'accord
lorsque le fait qu on à fond de la boîte
en 2016 sept ans il a commencé à faire
des enceintes sans fil on a commencé à
avoir des prix on a fait des casques
sans fil ont eu des prix aussi on a fait
des écouteurs santé on a encore eu les
frais du sport du voyage etc
mais l'année dernière la grosse
différence on la fait avec notre premier
modèle troué en restant par son sans fil
qu'on a on peut s'appeler antipodes ce
qui a fait sourire beaucoup de gens type
aux hoquets vrai chouette chouette
ok donc l'antipode l'adn de vos produits
d abord sur ce qu'est ce qui nous
différencie parce qu'à 1 millions
d'acteurs on a des marques à hyper connu
les sauts
aux apple etc on a les marques
distributeurs les chinois on a un projet
kickstarter mais nous pourquoi dit
d'accord diva c'est le côté design vers
l'excellence du design corps c'est parce
qu'on amène les meilleures fonctions du
marché en phase avec le marché en déça
time to market en anglais c'est à dire
que cette année on va t'apporter les
meilleures fonctions et derrière on peut
si on a un prix relativement content et
briquets auxquels comprend d'une part à
trois oui forcément d'accord alors les
produits phares qu'on peut qu'ils sont
en tout cas que toi que tu seras ans ou
plus
maintenant à lille fra 2018 quand je
précise que vous seriez pas là il
fallait 2018 on est en train de sortir
notre deuxième génération de d'écouteurs
100% sans fil donc après antipodes on
est en train de sortir deux modèles en
fait nomades et nomade plus ok cool sur
lesquels on a amélioré différents points
balles meilleure connexion plus stable
plus de latence de tout 5.0 bluetooth un
bain exactement quelle jeunesse avec le
budget sur quatre mois d'avancé
on était en 4.2 puis on vient d'évoluer
sur la nouvelle génération comme ça tu
te perds plus facilement connexion plus
stable un meilleur ça carbure voilà
c'est clair beurre ça passe biotope
deuxième truc qui est sympa sur les
nouveaux modèles nomades que je montre
un petit coup ça va être ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'avoir usurpé leur en
stéréo très peu de confiance proposé
l'année dernière mais accor va le propos
et on vient avec deux versions une qui
va me proposer
15h02 écoute avec le boîtier est une
élection 80 à 180
ça c'est juste unique on a une power
l'anc deux heures on s'est rendu compte
des habitudes des gens avaient un casse
d'un côté une première banque de l'or
pour leur banque ces jeux qu'on a pour
recharger les smartphones à la base oui
c'est vrai la moitié de charge c'est ça
d'habitude on ne sai on va recharger son
smartphone une deux trois fois ce
marteau general bocquet et là on peut
faire ça avec la boîte du trouvère et de
l'écouteur sans fil tu peux également
chargé ton smartphone wave ou alors tu
vas jusqu'à 180 heures de musique en
lecture gros tube alors typiquement le
produit qu'on a là celui là on a combien
d'heures avec ses produits
celui ci on est à 15 heures 15 heures
d'autonomie à 10 heures d'autonomie on a
deux petits bugs qui sont séparés
bon voilà c'est et de granges te dis on
a un boîtier de 15 heures et on en a un
autre plus grosse et pour le modèle
blanc bat le plus qui fait 180 180
heures et avec tu me dis tiens tu peux
aussi recharger son smartphone avec ont
chargé des groupes j'ai rechargé pas
manger leurs charges et bien pourquoi
qui se connecte en usb 2 3 ou mieux se
baisser ou ce que tu veux je viens
d'avoir le câble adapté et tu peux les
recharger doute qu'elle écoule que ces
normes 187 t'attend de faire des paris
tokyo
l'aller-retour à présent la ans vise un
public de voyageurs plus en plus des
gens ce voyage se balade
[Musique]
alors quels usages des produits
forcément pour écouter de la musique
course aussi running sont alors là
dessus on a des particularités on va y
utiliser ça pourquoi pour écouter de la
musique dans ses transports pour
discuter donc avec les appels en stéréo
effectivement le mode sport il ya
beaucoup de gens qui courent avec qui
font du vélo et d'autres entraînements à
l'extérieur du sport outdoor est là il
faut faire attention au danger
s'il ya une voiture qui arrive pas loin
on a créé à un mode ça s'appelle le mode
sport audio sport en extérieur en fait
ce que permet d'entendre des bruits
alentours d'accord si une voiture arrive
frais de collecte est en train de faire
ton globine en gros tu va l'entendre et
du coup tu vas faire parce que le seul
cas ce qui est 100% l'adduction oui
c'est réduction de bruit à leur passif
c'est à verser pour le micro c'est pas
la réduction de bruit active pour couper
les avions connaissent l inverse
mais par contre le fait de mettre un
écouteur dans ton oreille ça te koop
linteau les chantiers pleurer là on
amplifie les sons extérieurs comme ça ça
te permet de percevoir tous les dangers
que le micro capte le son est de
restituer en fonction des le restitue en
même temps que j'écoute la musique du
coup il s'amplifie impulsion équiterre
est d'accord mais fais attention danger
cool sauf à mal mais capte pas mal être
donc stabilité forcément quand tu cours
stabilité voilà on a aussi un maintien
parfait on a utilisé des millions
d'oreilles en forme et davantage c'est
combien de deuxième génération dont on
est déjà une expertise nous tiennent
parfaitement pour tous les sports léger
on va dire qu'on n'a même pas besoin des
led dans l'oreille pour le cuir
parfaitement
il ya une stabilité vraiment
irréprochable et également ce qui va
être intéressant c'est de se dire que en
position dans l'oreille pour la
conférence est tout petit et c'est hyper
sable je peux bouger ne devra pas du
tout
c'est vachement bien là on est content
on est sur la catégorie star le 100%
sans fil c'est ce qui va fonctionner
mieux annuel cette année on avait déjà
un excellent produit qu'on est en train
de changer prix on a deux nouveautés qui
sont magnifiques que tout le monde
s'arrache
donc tout va bien moi c'est plutôt
prometteur n'a carrément le moribond oui
ça se retrouver les produits dits la
core team
alors pour l'instant mais bush tribus et
chef marc berthier je fais orange chez
boulanger vrai en ligne on peut nous
trouver sur amazon com citant le jeu
vous aimez des liens dans la description
en temps vous pouvez aller trop loin
donc ça vous pourrez voir tous les
produits mais globalement l'avantagé
c'est que maintenant on va quand même
existe depuis quelques années on est
référence un petit peu partout pour les
produits génial tu entames de culte mais
vous étiez sur terre bien placé voilà
quels sont les tarifs
sapho que c'est à dire les antipodes de
notre dernier produit stor leurs prêts
cei va partir à 79 à partir du mois
prochain alors qu'elle était à 119 donc
on est à 80 euros sur un modèle qui est
encore numéro 1 chez 01net
ok et nos nouveaux modèles en bluetooth
1.0 en co2 clos modèle nomade sera 99
euros le modèle nomade plus avec la
power banque intégrée va être à 119
euros
119e l'idée c'est quoi c'est de se dire
que les utilisateurs apple pour plutôt
aller vers interposés ont les moyens de
dépenser 160 180 euros pour un écouteur
nous on vise les utilisateurs pour
android
il était en brouille d'hachette
généralement un smartphone un peu moins
cher et on se dit qu'avoir aux produits
pour tous ses utilisateurs produits en
stock avec divers combats et cool
ok bon bah écoute top a remercié le
rajouter bas vive nous avez vu l'état
[Musique]